this year's silver medal honors go to
Sean wines from Columbia University for
his film entitled high maintenance you
might as well come up because everyone
seems to this is a comedy that proves
that everything can go wrong that can go
wrong will go wrong it's like soham said
it's just been such an amazing week at
such an amazing experience with making
this film and showing it to an audience
and having an audience hopefully laugh
at it and the last thing you think when
you're making a movie about a fake penis
surgery is that the Academy is going to
give you anything so it's been great I
wanted to thank a few people my producer
Bridget Leibowitz who's here went to
Columbia with me all my friends from
Columbia who are here we don't get to
bring our our producers up on stage but
we all have amazing producers who have
done amazing work on our film so it's
great that bridget is here other people
from Columbia my thesis advisor Eric
Mendelson who is as kind of personal and
artistic and sundance ii of filmmakers
you can be but who treated this
ridiculous comedy with a lot of respect
and a lot of enthusiasm and help me get
it to the best it could be my parents
for being so supportive for so long with
me being a filmmaker despite me making
mostly vulgar sex comedies I think they
think they did something wrong but most
of all I want to thank the people who
worked on the film I don't want to name
everybody because it's would take
forever and I forget people but all of
the crew all of the cast and in New York
have been so amazing people we shot over
nights in New York in January outside
and freezing cold we shot a 20-hour day
one day I shouldn't say I'm never going
to work in this town but everybody that
comes and all everybody that works for
free and drives vans and moves equipment
and makes lunch and wants to help out on
films and we help out on their films and
that community that I'm sure all the
other filmmakers here as well have had
with their friends at the schools
they've known to is the most amazing
thing about film school to me it has
been so great and lastly just to thank
acad it's been such a great privilege to
be here and experience this week and be
with the other filmmakers who have been
so great and made such great films and
are such nice fun people it's really
something I'll never forget so thank you